Влада України запевняє, що все населення безкоштовно вакцинують від коронавірусу. У своєму відеоблозі президент Зеленський розповів,
що у першу чергу щеплення зроблять медпрацівникам, військовим, правоохоронцям, вчителям та особам з груп ризику.
Але це, по суті, й уся конкретна інформація про плани української влади щодо вакцинації. Усе решта - лише декларації.
Приміром, 11 листопада президент Зеленський розповів, що попросив канцлерку Німеччини Анґелу Меркель сприяти в отриманні українцями
поставок німецько-американської вакцини від Biontech. Однак в Україні наразі відсутня інфраструктура для транспортування і зберігання цієї вакцини,
адже це можливо лише за вкрай низької температури -80 градусів. Так вважає й експерт Ради нацбезпеки України Сергій Комісаренко.
Він висловлюється за придбання вакцини американської компанії "Модерна", яку легше транспортувати і зберігати.
Разом з тим Комісаренко оптимістично заявив, що всіх українців вакцинують до кінця 2021 року.
Насправді український уряд ще навіть не має орієнтовної дати початку щеплення в Україні.
Україна розраховує на безкоштовну партію вакцини від глобального фонду Covax - приблизно 8 мільйонів доз.
Утім, за даними фонду, цього слід очікувати не раніше, ніж у другому кварталі 2021-го, а найімовірніше - лише у травні.
Для порівняння: у багатьох західних країнах, зокрема у США та Німеччині, планують розпочати щеплення вже в середині грудня.
Ці країни не гають часу і вже нині інтенсивно працюють над логістикою, як максимально швидко провести масову вакцинацію від COVID-19.
У Німеччині створюють спеціальні центри для швидкого масового щеплення.
У Берліні - із населенням 4 мільйони, майже як у Києві - їх відкриють шість, зокрема на території колишнього аеропорту "Тегель", на льодовому катку
і навіть на велодромі, де зазвичай проходять спортивні змагання або концерти. Тут за лічені тижні зможуть вакцинувати сотні тисяч берлінців.
Наразі це важко уявити, тому я створив модель з "лего". Це місце вакцинації. Ось тут робитимуть щеплення людям у п'ятьох кабінах.
А перед цим отут проходитиме анамнез. Таких осередків у залі буде 15.
Утім, облаштувати центр - лише один із викликів. У Берліні хочуть уже в перші шість тижнів вакцинації зробити щеплення близько одному мільйону людей.
Тобто майже 20 тисяч на день. Для цього треба знайти достатньо медпрацівників.
На сімейних лікарів німці не розраховують - ті не можуть полишити своїх пацієнтів. А ще необхідні також добровольці для адміністративних функцій.
Нам доведеться звернутися за допомогою до інших гуманітарних організацій, до Бундесверу, лікарень, аби залучити достатньо персоналу
для проведення вакцинації. Адже йдеться не про кілька тисяч щеплень - ми говоримо про мільйони щеплень.
Необхідну інфраструктуру у Німеччині планують підготувати до середини грудня. Але це - лише верхівка айсберга.
Величезним викликом європейці вважають логістику доставки вакцин.
Адже йдеться про гігантський обсяг - близько 10 мільярдів доз - у світових масштабах.
Кількість 10 мільярдів доз відштовхується від чисельності світового населення - 7,8 мільярда людей.
Також враховано коефіцієнт  бажаного колективного імунітету - 60%. І те, що вакцину потрібно робити двічі.
Аби прищепити мільярди людей у світі, знадобиться 15 тисяч рейсів і 200 тисяч контейнерів з медикаментом, оцінює німецька логістична компанія DHL.
І доставка багатьох мільйонів окремих посилок у холодильних боксах до конкретних адресатів. При цьому ланцюг охолодження не можна переривати.
Ані під час транспортування, ані під час тимчасового зберігання в аеропортах, ані під час доставки до кінцевих адресатів.
Як у літаку, так і під час експресдоставки охолодження потрібно реалізувати за допомогою сухого льоду. Сухий лід у повітряних вантажоперевезеннях -
небезпечна речовина, оскільки він випаровується і витісняє повітря для дихання. Словом, багато аспектів, на які слід звертати увагу.
А як досягти віддалених регіонів - без аеропортів поблизу та без шосе, якими можуть проїхати рефрижератори?
У сфері логістики ми намагаємося мислити інноваційно. Наприклад, чи доцільно залучити дрони, щоб пришвидшити доставку у віддалені регіони?
І чи маємо ми там достатньо медичного персоналу, аби професійно провести щеплення?
Швидко доставити вакцину від коронавірусу по цілому світу - це "завдання століття". І країни з доброю інфраструктурою тут, безперечно, у виграші.
Якщо ви спитаєте мене, де б я хотіла, щоб мешкали мої батьки - у промислово розвиненій країні чи у бідній країні, то моя відповідь очевидна: в промисловій.
Там більше шансів вчасно отримати вакцину.
В Україні, на думку фахівців, теж очікуються проблеми з організацією щеплень у регіонах. Відповідей поки немає і на низку інших важливих логістичних питань.
Скільки вакцини вже замовлено та коли вона надійде в Україну? Як буде організовано доставку, зокрема в умовах глибокого охолодження?
Чи будуть створені спеціальні центри імунізації тощо. Імовірно, крапки над "і" розставить стратегія вакцинації МОЗ, яку міністерство планує представити лише
наступного тижня. Тим часом Нацслужба здоров'я України застерігає щодо нестачі грошей на вакцинацію.
На закупівлю вакцини у проєкті держбюджету на 2021 рік запланували 2,6 млрд гривень. Навіть з урахуванням знижок для України у ціні препаратів,
цих грошей удвічі менше, ніж потрібно. Квола підготовка до вакцинації помножена на брак коштів на вакцину
не залишає українцям сподівань на швидку та організовану імунізацію проти коронавірусу.